- Please welcome Whitney
Cummings everybody!
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering and applauding)
Hi! You look adorable!
- Thank you!
- What? And it says Seattle
on it, I like your belt.
You look ad-
- Thank you so-
- Wait, can I have one?
- No!
- What?
(audience laughing)
- I just carry these around for myself.
- I feel like all we're
missing is a mechanical bull.
Do these light up?
(audience laughing)
- Okay, they blink.
Hold on, it's not that dark.
Can we turn the lights off?
(Whitney and audience laughing)
- We'll just do this.
- Yes, and then they, hold on, here.
Put it, do you see how
they light up? Hold on.
I'm trying to figure
out a way to show you.
- Well, wait, we're
all about LA this week.
So what are some of your,
what's like one of your favorite
places you would tell someone to go.
- LA, well my favorite thing
in the world to do in LA
is go to thrift stores.
As you can tell, by the way I dress.
I love going to the magic
castle. Have you been there?
- Okay, everybody's talking about it.
(audience clapping)
I've never been, but everybody's
talked about it to me.
I love magic, is it a real magic show?
- It's um, it's magical if
you like seeing magicians
get out of their crappy car,
and walk in, and then be like,
I am a magician.
It's like, I just saw you
get out of your Camaro
and bub a cigarette, but it's still,
just park in the right place.
You don't see the magicians
before they put on
their magical outfits.
- You don't want to see behind the-
- You don't want to see the before.
- Okay, you don't want to
see the before here either.
(women laughing)
I feel you, magicians.
- I just have the property
brothers do my makeup.
Caulk, and grout, and chainsaws.
(Kelly laughing)
But I love the magic castle.
You go, there's all these different rooms
with all these different magicians.
And I just actually met a
female magician in Vegas.
Her name is Jen Kramer,
cause I'm such a magic fan.
But I did a joke in my last special about
why are there no female magicians?
Because I find that like in our
society, men, when they lie,
they get rewarded, right?
They're like good businessmen.
When men are manipulative,
you know, they're good bosses.
You know like, but when a woman lies,
everyone gets very uncomfortable.
People don't like when women lie,
that's why there's no female magicians.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And so I did this, cause
when a man does magic,
and lies to you we're like, whoa, magic.
- He's amazing.
- But if a woman were to be a magician,
she would like pull a bunny out of a hat,
and everyone would be
like, see, I knew it.
You can't trust 'em. You cannot
trust them. (Kelly laughing)
You can't trust 'em,
these hoes ain't loyal.
I knew it!
(Kelly laughing)
And then, so of course I say,
there's no female magicians.
I'm trying to make sure
I'm not missing anybody.
But then she wins one of these big shows,
America's Got Talent or
something. Her name is Jen Kramer.
And I go into my DMs,
which I don't do often.
And I had so, I mean,
it's a lot of eggplants,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
but it's like eggplant,
eggplant, eggplant.
- Good for you.
- There is a female magician
in Vegas and dah, dah, dah.
So I got to meet her finally
when I went to Vegas,
and see a female do magic,
which I just had never
really met a female magician,
even though every woman's a
magician, we can make people.
But.
(Kelly and Whitney laughing)
(audience cheering)
- You're welcome.
That's, I've never heard of one either.
- Yeah.
- Isn't that interesting? It's just-
- I never thought about
that either, but nope,
never known one-
- It's a very male-dominant,
I mean, in magic normally,
they are very feminist.
They like to saw the
women in half. Normally.
So, she was the first person who was like,
can I do the cool stuff,
and not just lay here
and get sawed in half?
So she's just like so awesome.
- Your current comedy
tour is called Touch Me.
It's the Touch Me tour, which is so great.
Just relaxed.
(Whitney and Kelly laughing)
- It's just so awkward.
- Just get comfortable.
no, but what were some-
(Kelly and audience laughing)
wait, I have to know,
before you got to, I'm in such
a short dress that I can't.
- You can't do any of what I'm doing.
(Kelly laughing)
- I was like, ah, I'm gonna
flash you some spanks.
Yeah, that's gonna be hot.
So what were your other
like title options?
Cause I love that you landed on tour.
- Touch Me.
- [Both] Touch Me tour.
- Well, I came up with the
Touch Me tour. It was pre-Delta.
Pre-this other thing when it was like,
you know, because we want
a year where it was like,
we weren't able to like
hug our own friends
and family members.
And you know, I basically
was like, like, like,
you know, home is so deprived of touch.
So I couldn't even like
say hi to my own nieces.
I couldn't hug people, you know?
And then when I started
going out and touring,
and when people start, you
know, we started to get tested.
And then all of a sudden
I found myself just like
being such a sexual predator with people.
I was just like, I was like,
if holding a hug a little
too long is illegal,
lock me up, because I just
would not let go of people.
- It's actually real.
Like that's a real thing.
Like just being able to hug someone again.
And like-
- The oxytocin,
this sort of, our bodies
don't know what's going.
It's just, it was all fear, fear, fear.
And it went from, you know,
all of a sudden people
that wore masks were like scary. Right?
You called the police if
you saw someone in a mask,
and then, you know, three months later,
if someone's not in a mask,
you're like, you know,
everything changed.
Now we're-
- Vaccinated? Did you get tested today?
(Kelly laughing)
- We're comfortable with
people in full masks,
like on our ring cameras, just knocking.
Like we're just like,
that guy's responsible.
Like remember when masks were scary?
So everything just changed so fast.
And I just thought I'm
such a, a physical person.
I like to, you know,
look people in the eye,
and I just found, you know,
and so I was like, okay, on this tour,
we're gonna do meet and greets.
We're gonna do everything
responsibly and safe,
but I want to get back to
being able to take photos
with people, and hugging people.
And I mean, I don't want anyone to,
this emotional trauma of being
scared of each other forever,
as long as we're being responsible,
can we get back to be like human beings?
And, and, you know.
(audience applauding)
Like when I meet someone I respect,
I want to shake their hand
and look them in the eye.
So I called it the Touch
Me tour because that's,
you know, I was like, let's
build up my immune system.
Let's see, let's see what I can handle.
And then I went on tour
and I was doing this thing
where I was talking about
sort of all the old men
in the audience that I
love dating old guys,
especially now since COVID is happening.
And they could like marry me,
you look like you're gonna get sick soon.
And um,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
it's like the perfect time
to date older men with money.
(Kelly laughing)
And so I am an entrepreneur,
and if you're not inspired,
I can't help you.
(audience cheering and applauding)
It's called a business brain.
So there was this guy
that was like, older,
and I was like, we all
have to protect you.
Like everyone.
I was just making sure
that everything was okay.
And that he was, you know, sort of safe.
And I brought him up on stage
because I was so worried about
him, maybe, you know, you know,
getting COVID or something.
So I brought him on stage with me,
and then I was like, okay,
what is your dying wish?
And he couldn't think of one.
(audience laughing)
- He couldn't think of one?
- He couldn't think of one,
you know, he lived a full life,
except I was like, have you
ever touched fake boobs before?
(Kelly laughing)
To which he said no, and I
was like, well, here we go.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Now's your time.
(Whitney and Kelly laughing)
- Did he?
- Yes, he just grabbed my boobs,
and it like made his night.
And I was like, okay, from now on.
- Was he kinda like, I guess...
- No, he was very.
- Oh, he was just like, damn
straight, you just said do it.
- I was joking, and he's like,
I was like, okay, well that was...
(Kelly laughing)
I am gonna need to work through that.
But yeah. So it's,
it's like playing bloody knuckles.
He probably hurt himself.
(Whitney laughing)
- Bloody knuckles?
I love the reference.
- It's not that fun of an experience,
but at least, you know,
we got to check that off the list.
So now it's kind of,
I'm just trying to be able
to connect with people,
give things out at shows.
You know, we did a mask show in Vegas,
and I brought a bunch
of like fun, silly masks
for people to wear over their paper masks.
Cause it's like, we don't want
to feel like we're performing
at Guantanamo Bay either. You know.
(Kelly laughing) You
don't want to wear masks.
We don't want to have to look at it.
So I brought a bunch of little, like,
really fun ones and silly ones.
And I was like, let's
just turn this into like
an eyes wide shut, weird,
like creepy sex party,
Halloween extravaganza.
- That movie did shock me.
(audience applauding)
- And so figuring out a way
to like move forward safely,
but still like, you know,
give people joy and connect
people in a way that's safe.
And just trying to, I think
musicians are, you know,
you're trying to figure that out too.
- 100%, and it's a hard thing to kind of,
a lot of people are still canceling,
but a lot of people are
like, well, let's do this.
Like as long as we're trying to be safe,
every wearing masks we're trying,
but I love that you're making
like innovative and creative,
I would expect nothing less from you.